انها صبيحه يوم السادس والعشرين من يناير
لعام 2001 وهو يوم ليس عاديا في جمهوريه
الهند فهو يوم الجمهوريه الخامس والخمسين
وهي ذكرى يجب ان تكون مصدر فخر للبلاد لكن
الامر لم يكن كذلك حيث تحول الاحتفال الى
يوم حزين عندما تعرضت ولايه غوجارات
الحدوديه مع باكستان لزلزال مدمر تسبب في
وقوع اكثر من عشرين الف قتيل وخسائر بشريه
وماديه كبرى فماذا حدث
قبل ان تدق الساعه التاسعه صباحا ضربت
منطقه كوتش في ولايه ججارات هزه ارضيه شعر
بها السكان بمعظم انحاء البلاد رصد مركز
الزلزال على بعد 20 كيلومترا شمال شرق
مدينه بوج الواقعه في الولايه وامتدت
اثاره لجميع انحاء الولايه بما في ذلك
البلدات والقرى الكبيره
بلغت قوه الزلزال 7.7 درجات على مقياس
ريختر ما كان كافيا لاحداث دمار شامل في
المباني والممتلكات العامه والخاصه انهار
نحو 300 الف منزل فيما تعرض ما يقرب من
مليون منزل لدمار جزئي فتحولت مدن الولايه
السياحيه ذات الشواطئ الجميله والمزارات
الدينيه والتراثيه والثقافيه الى ركام
في مدينه احمد اباد العاصمه التجاريه
للولايه انهار اكثر من 70 مبنى سكنيا شاهق
الارتفاع كمنهار مبنى الاتصالات في بوج ما
ادى الى عزل المنطقه عن بقيه الولايه كذلك
تعطلت مصادر الطاقه الكهربائيه وامدادات
المياه
اثر الزلزال بشكل خطير على ميناء كاندلا
اكثر الموانئ ازدحاما في الهند كما لحقت
اضرار جسيمه بارصفه الموانئ ومستودعات
التخزين ومعدات النقل البحري
تهدمت العديد من السدود الترابيه التي يصل
ارتفاعها الى نحو 20 مترا وتعطلت سدود
السكك الحديديه والطرق السريعه كما لحقت
الكثير من الاضرار بالطرق الرئيسيه لكن
اكثرها تاثرا كان توقف جسر سراج باري عن
العمل الذي يعد اهم الطرق التي تربط ولايه
غوجارات بمنطقه كوتش ولم يسمح سوى
للمركبات التجاريه الخفيفه بعبور الجسر
لمده 15 يوما تقريبا
توقفت عشره الاف وحده صناعيه صغيره
ومتوسطه على الاقل عن الانتاج بسبب
الاضرار التي لحقت بالمصانع والالات توقف
العمل في الالاف من احواض الملح التي تعد
من اهم مصادر الرزق لابناء الولايه
والوافدين وفقد الاف من الحرفيين ورش
عملهم خصوصا في منطقه كوتش التي تزخر
بصناعه الاواني
تدخلت المنظمات المجتمعيه للتعامل مع
تبعات الكارثه بتقديم الدعم الغذائي
والطبيبي والنفسي للناجين كما قامت بانشاء
ملاجئ جديده لمئات الاسر واعاده تاهيل
المنازل المتضرره جزئيا
قالت الارقام الرسميه ان عشرين الف وسته
وثمانين شخصا لقوا حتفهم في الزلزال فيما
اثرت الكارثه على خمسه عشر مليون وتسعمائه
الف شخص اي ما يعادل 42 وسته من مئه في
المئه من اجمالي عدد السكان وتم تقدير
الخساره الاقتصاديه بسبب هذا الزلزال بنحو
خمسه مليارات دولار امريكي
بعد وقت قصير من زلزال كوجرات عندما كانت
الهند وبقيه العالم تستجيب بسخاء لنداءات
الخاصه باموال الاغاثه في حالات الكوارث
اعلنت الحكومه عن ضريبه اضافيه للتعاطي مع
الضرر الناجم عن الزلزال
مضى اكثر من عشرين عاما على الكارثه دون
ان تمحى ذكر الزلزال الذي اعتبر بين
الاكثر فتكا خلال القرن الحادي والعشرين